it's made from did Allah peace be with
you
greetings the best of greetings the same
greeting that Jesus Moses and the last
the final messenger said of mankind
apart Muhammad they greeted her
followers with this greeting a peace and
we're going to eat you with that
greeting here today Muslims are from all
around the world that's right we got a
Greek Muslim Hamza notices here on the D
show to tell us his story on how he came
to this beautiful way of life it's loud
submission to the One God we'll be right
back with his story here in the D show
[Music]
peace be with you why they come salam wa
rahmatullahu a better cat to be with you
and you broke Ana's boy how the people
in Greece okay I get like that Greek
food
not really so now what did you become an
Arab you were Greek now that you do
you're Muslim you think I have the
ability to change my DNA I mean what do
you think this is so you're a Greek
Muslim yes is that that's like you know
hey amazing there's a lot there a lot of
Greek Muslims in that yeah now people
who have descended from other places but
people from Greece accepting this way of
life yeah honey is growing this big
organizations that Islamic and calling
people to Islam and we have some message
it and people are calling to this
beautiful way of life how are you now
how did you get to where you're at now
you were a background what Christian
Christian stroke humanist stroke secular
so you were just it was a big buffet hey
it was a buffet there's a buffet a
little buffet and so tell us a little
about yourself before Islam okay well my
name is Andreas that was my name and the
rest georgous and I came I was born in
London in England my dad is from Athens
but originally from Northwest Greece my
mom is from the Greek part of Cyprus she
came to England because of 1974 invasion
the Turkish invasion of one-third of the
island so my parents met and I came
about and I was brought up in an era
called Hackney it's equivalent to the
Bronx at that time Hackney was a bit of
a ghetto rough area we used to live in
this block of flats based in a ditch
like for example on the second floor the
second floor was in line with the ground
so this is a kind of environment I was I
was brought up in and it wasn't easy
though some drugs in the environment
gangs Chinese gangs especially the
Triads you weren't a Chinese gang I was
here I was in 14k 14k there was like
whooshing whoa
14k I was in 14k this way these trials
of the stars on them and all these
symbols we seek I like choppers in our
bags but you know I wasn't heavily
involved
I was always still a really good kid it
was very compassionate my dad brought me
up in a very compassionate way always
talking about love and compassion and
stuff but you know you could be a
product of your environment sometimes so
that was the kind of upbringing in kind
of environment although it's quite
intelligent kid is well at the same time
I was in two worlds I think many kids
have that issue as well
you know good family background
compassion love the intelligent but they
want to conform to society and or chew I
don't want to do this they want to
conform and this is how social norms are
developed in society by human beings
wanting to conform we want to be certain
we don't want to be alienating that's
why islam teaches you to be a leader to
be a shepherd not the sheep so you bring
your flock and this is even our
community in Chicago
wherever we are though we have a
distinct character because we worship
the create another creation if that's
the case you'd be distinct and one want
to follow you know you follow them but
unfortunately to have that Islamic
background because I was improper as a
Muslim and so that was my kind of
environment called were you around that
time well it's from the age of 14 to
1914 so what happened at that age of
fourteen fifty you're going a long life
you know you're just doing what normal
kids are doing music you know again that
was a bit unique though as well because
my dad would take me to like the role
School of Music and then classical
guitar I used to know how to read and
write music as well still in Chinese
Mandarin me Han piaoliang
I said you're very pretty so you speak
Chinese no no I used to know her here
and then after when I became Muslim I
stopped and I was going to other studies
but I was dabbling into Chinese
different cultures willing to come foo
Wing Chun Kung Fu Xiao Ling still why a
mantis yeah so these I was very cultural
at the same time so that one was a
double life or triple life I was leading
and you know women and stuff like that
so I was a confused kid I you know who I
was if I'm not perspective but I always
had a good respect for traditions like
Buddhism and Islam and nice to read
around these things quite a lot even at
a young
age so how does the salon fit in did you
meet a Muslim
did you read something on internet how
were you at it were you seeking guidance
because a lot of the people we talked to
will ask them have you ever asked God
for guidance because we believe if you
ask the creator for guidance he'll for
somebody wait uh were you like okay did
she break your heart and you just was
the nightclubs getting played out did
the other gang kid beating up on you or
what did you did you like get to a point
where you're like I'm just sick of
everything what was it well I tell you
what it is I always wanted to know truce
my dad said to me always have an open
mind read every tradition so when I was
at high school I used to have a Muslim
friend he came from Bangladesh and he
was such a nice guy it was very distinct
he was a cool guy but he went amuck
about women who had honor women who
honored human beings who were very
distinct very principles won't change
they won't waver just to look good and
for me that I found that so attractive
and I wanted to be like him so he was
introducing me to some very slowly he
gave me this booklet called faith in
progress by this brother could Jamal
Howard right and it was about that God
exists
and you gotta think refractors the Quran
teaches you think of effect it does they
just have blind faith think after let
alone you know use your intellect your
mind more free own force hakuna for that
top zero there's a verbatim word of God
the Koran yes this is the verbatim Word
of God
well Fiona come fi dad stop recording it
in Arabic it is Arabic the son said
you're out you're Greek yes and you've
learned Arabic also the original like
the reason I'm bringing this up if you
want it to follow let's say you're
Christian wanting to follow let's say
the original teachings of G you can't
you don't have the read you don't know
you don't see someone quoting Aramaic
yes you don't like you don't see that
cuz we hear you're quoting the original
verb a death of God in its original text
yes this is why a professor and gennaker
Neurath in the Cambridge companion to
the Koran she says the crown we have
today in Arabic is the same as we had
1400 years ago so continue I'm sorry for
cutting your service Akuma Fidel tips
Arun God says in the Quran which means
and in themselves do they know see the
Quran is the word yet that Karen
which means for those who reflect now
this doesn't mean any type of reflecting
like oh you have a nice beard
Eddy I like your job the way you have
you had some guy man not that kind of
reflecting this reflection is the thing
that you're reflecting upon you must
think about its implications what does
it mean what does it mean Quran which to
think doesn't mean to be blind that's
what it says are you gonna follow your
forefathers even if they were based on
falsehood so this small booklet was a
fascinating booklet open my mind to
something I thought I was like wow I
thought religions were all about blind
faith awful religions were about not
searching the truth and just just just
believing in your heart but Islam is so
unique is believing in your heart
understanding is part of your nature but
also agrees with the mind and that's the
beautiful thing about Islam so that
started me off although I didn't become
a Muslim I didn't become a Muslim so
what happened what happened was how much
in university study psychology so
studying psychology and I was the kind
of guy but I was always a bit rough on
the edges I was it was a nice guy not my
dad you know I want you to copy my dad
my dad would help everybody so my
friends say to me we have a dissertation
to do we have to give it in it's the
last day of few more hours left few more
minutes left can I copy your conclusion
and I was like I was a nice guy to take
it copy it what happens University finds
out I get in trouble they get in trouble
I have to start the year again this was
the second year I was upset I had to
take one module again i sat in the
tribunal if you like I said really I
didn't copy anybody they copied me I'm
telling you I this is my spelling
mistake this is the way I write and they
knew that but they had to be fair and
said look everyone goes because you gave
them your work so what happened was I
took your honest I working as a project
officer to become a project manager so I
was working in in the British government
I was working for the police IT
organization at the time I was learning
more about project management I was
given a lot of money a lot of project
management training so I entered in that
kind of office environment and then I
was still reading more about Islam but
Christmas came and we went to a boat
party mm-hmm and what happened that boat
party was basically a small milestone to
change the rest of my life from a boat
party from a bullet party mm-hmm
so I'll tell you about the boat party
maybe off to the break after the break
okay so don't go nowhere
know about this boat party here with
Hamza Tarsus and the Dean show is your
boss driving them crazy are you just
living from paycheck to paycheck party
to party and everything is just getting
tiring it's getting played out and
you're asking yourself what's this all
about what's the purpose
many people don't reflect like I mean
why am I here you're born to die and
then what do you got in between me it's
a big drama some days are good some days
are bad some days are sick some days are
sad we not we might not make it to 85
years old we might not make it till
tomorrow and this is something that we
need to think about the lights will go
on after the party and the party will
end and you will be alone and you will
have to be accountable for everything
you've done
life is not all about just chasing that
man or woman or that good time it's not
all about the baseball game in the
basketball game and chasing a position
and getting a lot of wealth and money
there's more to this life and it's up to
you to be sincere enough within yourself
and to want to know more what's the
purpose what's it all about light
many og people locked up the Sioux war
[Music]
back here on the D show and we're
getting our brother Hamza Torres Greek
Muslim didn't become an Arab you don't
obviously have to become an heir of an
Indian or anything if you're an American
you're American Muslim Muslim is simply
one who submits not to the creation but
to the crater and you're following the
best of mankind Muhammad peace be upon
him who's the last and final messenger
sent to mankind is it true
this is the same way that if you're
living during time of Jesus you would
have to follow his teachings not worship
Him yeah that's true yes so before we go
to the boat party now were you because
your family was Christian so did you
follow the teachings at all did you did
they believe that he was God he died for
the sins of the world did you believe
that well the thing with the Trinity and
the Incarnation is that it confuses all
the Greeks anyway so they just believe
in this man could Jesus he was a really
nice man and we just have to be really
nice to people that's the that's
Christianity in Greece now because I
mean the Greeks are thinking people they
got who well they're supposed to be a
hey you know logic original style and
now they tow and now Trinity comes in
exactly confuses them because they'll
think how can the divine majesty the
divine reality incarnate into human
being how can they be three persons and
one consciousness one essence but of
confusion so is it kind of just embedded
into the the race now okay they feel
like okay this is a part of us okay
we're Greek Greek guy Greek you can
attack you become another religion
you've left Greek well these like why
I've been called a traitor because I've
become a Muslim but yeah I try to
explain to do it that's not true you're
still Greek I'm still Greek of course I
like Greek food I love my parents the
parents love me I still speak Greek I
love Greek poetry I like Greek
literature and Tony some Iraqis he wrote
an amazing book or the detail beasts
hope wanted this very kind of
psychological social book show story is
fascinating I'm still Greek from that
perspective okay I still not a Greek
dance as well my show you later
so the boat party now we're at the boat
the boat party and basically I wasn't
the kind of guy that liked parties
anyway and I was more like gonna have a
conversation a bit of dinner maybe do a
workout go to do some kung fu you know I
have some friends but what happened was
is you know an interesting human being
came up to me
female and you know all of creation is
beautiful a lot creates everything
that's beautiful so I realized she was a
Muslim mm-hmm and I knew a lot about
Islam and I was really shocked I said
look woman I sit down and no dancing sit
down and she's shocked right she's like
what's going on I said you told her that
I was telling her that he was like
what's wrong with you
I said listen what's your name you're a
Muslim she shouldn't be do you think I
took the drink out of her hand I gave
her an orange juice and we start talking
about Islam and I start saying to you
know you shouldn't be doing this these
guys they're not even Muslim at the time
not Muslim your time her she's like you
are you some kind of Muftis scholar some
kind of mullah I don't know but you know
I know this reality they don't really
love you they don't they just use a
piece of flesh they objectify women in
this society but in Islam we see woman
as a holistic human being she's not just
a piece of arm and a piece of me and a
piece of leg and just some nice eyes
no we see everything in its oneness
hello holistic so we see that she's a
character she's preachers and
intellectual she's got a heart she's a
future mother all these beautiful things
that we want to connect with these guys
don't want that what are you doing here
she was shocked you could imagine right
so we exchanged numbers I go back to the
office
I lost her number nothing happens after
three months I got a call from the HR
department Human Resources bring bring
mr. Dizzy's it's so and so on the line
and he was the lady she somehow finai
where I worked
she found trace to me down she tracked
me down boy so I pick up the phone I'm
discussing with her so we we have some
kind some kind of a friendship or a
relationship he should have called it
that but even then it was emotionally
allowing me to learn more about Islam in
a way because even though she wasn't
practicing there is something about a
Muslim woman that wishes brought up in a
Muslim family it's like it's like a
purifier you can you could have a bottle
of water that's really muddy you know
the really small tablet
she put in then it cleans it up that's
what happens even if you know just the
Iman just the faith in God and knowing
that you don't worship creation you
worship the Creator that itself gives
you different kind of I don't have to
explain it bro it's like I know I know I
know aura and even though she wasn't
practicing she had that small belief and
that for me was so attractive not her
but I believe and what made her that she
loved kids so much I've never seen
anyone that loves kids like that right
so that attracted me to read furthest
was reading about Islam as well then I
was trying to teach you as well at the
same time so cut long story short she
had to move back home she was teaching
she had to move back home she was
studying and she took me back home get
married you know what happens and she
calls me after like a year or something
and I'm like what's going on you know my
dad picks up the phone gives me the
phone
and what does she say she says Andreas I
want to say something to you don't want
to really want to speak to you was like
wow what's going on here I want to let
you know that I'm wearing the hijab and
I'm praying five times a day amazing huh
isn't that amazing it means beauty bro
it means me too
it was it was beautiful it was beautiful
like a non-muslim a disbeliever could
facilitate someone's guidance and then
she put the phone down and then that
shocked me to me way back boom was like
a big right hand the one you gave me
earlier yeah like a big right hand and
I'm like how am I gonna do now what am I
gonna do with my life because it made it
real it wasn't just abstract ideas it
was like it affected a human being in a
profound way so I started to pray and I
remember praying and I heard you're in
taking this channel no I'm not a Muslim
but I'm praying bro
and I'm doing such that I remember a
college kid and now he's a doctor he's
one of the best doctors and he's a
wrestler as well in England he used to
train the English team his name's dr.
Amir one of the beautiful boys I met in
my life
and dr. Amir would come to college and
he'd be one of those distinct Muslims I
would worship the creation of the
creation and be very unique and I looked
up to him and he said you know when
we're in such their frustration just
like Jesus in the Bible he says he put
his face on the floor that's how you
prayed to God we pray that's how he's
very and he said when you're like this
you're closer to your Lord and that's
what I could remember from him and
that's why when mister
listen to this don't build it to the one
word that you say to people it could
affect someone for the rest of their
life
so I'm inside Judah and I'm screaming
I'm screaming to go and they help me so
what's this
oh that lychee treating God like he's
just like you know I'm talking about in
front of me what's up man helped me I
don't know what's going on and helped me
and then I'm keep on praying and keep on
praying I go to Greece I got to holla to
see my granddad and I have a Quran with
me and I learned Fatih in Arabic now
when you're screaming you were you it
was it screaming of guidance you're like
oh I just wanted another way you wanted
to know the law it's another way I said
look God you've always been in my life
I've never really rejected you
I used to even use the word Allah when I
was walking down the street and needed
help in my life said he got a life you
are Allah over you I just helped me so
what I was in such pain frustration I
was screaming out to him for guidance
for help I want to know the way okay
you see Steve now things are transpiring
you see the way it's he's facilitating
away you exactly know this would happen
now I see he was facilitate me by the
time I still was like I'm really
frustrated I go to Greece I don't dance
this time I don't drink that all this
time I don't stay up late this time I'm
at home reading an English translation
of the Quran I'm learning how to recite
Arabic I learn the first chapter of the
Quran I learned 112 chapter of the Quran
I'm learning chapters in Arabic who
Allah who I had continued work with just
that you said the first chapter define
it in English the first chapter is sort
of Fatih which means the opening and
it's the chapter we used as a necessary
for our prayers and that's a chapter so
we say it starts off by saying
alhamdulillah horrible I mean all
grateful thanks and praise due to the
Lord of everything that exists to the
word greater not Jesus not man not
creation on a stone on a book on a wall
on a pulp but the Creator
okay so I learned that in Arabic and I
start to pray even more I came back to
England and I start praying then I gave
up existential crisis which means what
it means to exist I just had a crisis
and I'll just in my own to press mode
then you know that guy was talking to
you about I've been going kid about yeah
you're the world
he looks am i doing a Friday October the
4th 2002 and he says to me sit in my car
I know you know the truth I gave you the
booklet remember that booklet faith in
progress
Islam's the truth proof of God for the
creator he said this the truth and you
know I was like yeah I do know but I
can't be Muslim it's not here yet so
what did he do he gave me an amazing
story on death I can't even describe
couldn't lue nuts in there it could tell
milk every soul is gonna taste death the
Quran says it was such an amazing story
amazing narrative imagery I don't
remember if I remember that effect it
was to numb when I went back home and
all of a sudden everything I knew
abstractly intellectually came straight
here
October the 1st 2002 I took a taxi to
the Central Mosque those 50 brothers
there and I took my Shahada my first
prayer was the heart and I didn't need
no one to teach me because I'll already
help me you've already learned how to
pray amazing amazing we'll be right back
with more with the rest of the story
here on the Deen show
you
it's killing of innocent human beings
human life is precious back here on the
D show and we're talking to our brother
our Greek brother who didn't become an
Arab he is a Muslim still Greek and it's
amazing you accepted Islam the same way
that Jesus lived
Jesus a little Islam didn't it yes it
did Jesus submitted to the will of God
that's Islam
so did Moses Abraham and all the
messengers of God including the last and
final mission apart my Hamid peace be
upon him they were teaching us how to
get to paradise how to get the pleasure
of God how to worship God and now you
decided to do that you took the
declaration of faith now the Shahada
what did that entail well the Shahada is
that you witness that there is no deity
worthy of worship but God Allah and
interestingly linguistically the the
word the name Allah is genderless and
cannot have a plural and Allah some
linguists in the Islamic tradition say
is el la which means the deity so
there's no deity worthy of worship apart
from the deity the true dating the true
God and you witnessed I bore witness
that Muhammad upon whom be peace is his
last and final messenger that's the same
testimony the swaying to if you were
living during the time of Jesus yes
you'd have to make that same day does
testimony day you'd have to declare that
there's nothing worthy of worship except
the crater and every Allah in Aramaic
Allah ha exactly and then Jesus is the
Messenger of God right so you didn't do
anything different
oh no does that I accepted reality I for
example say oh that's a really nice
jacket Eddie that's accepting reality
it's a nice jacket aslam is accepting
reality because some people think you
know there will be fireworks and angels
and the whole universe is gonna crumble
when you take the declaration of faith
but when I speak to you something look
you already know it's in your nature
you've been committed your mind just
accept reality and that's what I did I
accepted the
there is truly no deity worthy of
worship but God and Muhammad upon him
peace is his final messenger there's no
other explanation now if someone is just
okay they turning in late at night and
they see us and you know they have that
void and they're listening but then they
fall back into the many pitfalls you
know again I talked about you know the
movies the music the things that just
warps the mind you get in the car you go
to bed wake up to music wake up to move
everything is just you know
entertainment but why is this so
important to think about this reality
you know because when we die it's
finished you can't come back you can't
watch the test is over then it's
Hellfire is that right yep that's the
warning that all the messages I think
what the warning will avoid the Hellfire
and paradise paradise is for forever
eternal happiness bliss I mean why is it
I mean why you you mentioned that you're
the Muslim front he mentioned death yes
that snap you out of it of course it did
because the way he mentioned it I don't
remember what he said it was so poor
take the way he described I remember him
saying something like imagine I just
stab you right now and then he described
the whole process huh people that you
love your family friends and every this
became so real so what the Quran does is
there is a realistic book it's a
psychological book he wants to make
reality appear to you in front of your
face this is why you know Allah God in
the Quran he tries to dismantle our own
egos and arrogance because I eat gone
arrogance is the barrier to God isn't it
yeah and like the way the Quran does
this is by saying you're gonna be one
buffet you're gonna be in your graves
wake up you think I lost forever you're
gonna take over the world you think
you're you're the king of kings and also
the Quran says remember where you came
from you would despise fluid you're a
baby you can even clean your own bottom
you can even feed yourself and now
you're arrogant you think you can match
the mountains in high anything you're
self-sufficient exactly and that's that
and so that the act of self-sufficiency
the state of social sufficiency is a
barrier to Islam now I want to tell
people though say you're listening to
this message and you listen to brother
Eddie or you've spread something nice
and in to know you have Muslim friends
and you like this tradition of Islam you
accept it's the truth but you think I'm
still going to the club I'm still doing
this I'm still doing that I'm not worthy
never never ever despair of the mercy of
Allah of God
this is one of shakedowns Satan's tricks
he wants to make you single you know
worthy to now accept this tradition oh
no you're not worthy to pray or you know
whether to repent to Allah Allah says o
ya ibadi o my believing servants do not
despair of the mercy of God forgives all
sins and even says despairing is an act
of the disbeliever only the disbelievers
despair
so if you want to be that believe you
know you shouldn't be in a state of
despair that God always wants you turns
he allows you turns he wants you back
all the time you know and that's what
happens sometimes and it happened to me
you know you'll be watching reading
something nice then you go back into
your old ways and you think I'm not
ready to go back no good wants you back
door's always always open now I'm of
death to tell us now we're almost out of
time so I have a few more points that
gonna cover for the person I had a bad
experience you know and they start to
put all religions in the same boat they
say look I don't want to follow an organ
organized religion organized by man or
men and and then they go and take a
psychological Asif e-class yeah College
and then they just you know they just
leave it all they paint them all the
same brush and they put Islam in his
book it's saying it's all man-made what
do you have to say well the first thing
is that people have to read the Quran
that's the number one point this is our
basis this is our premise this is the
assumption this is our foundation and
it's justified because we know it's true
because the Quran challenges the whole
of mankind you found me a book that
intellectually challenges mankind very
brave from that perspective in chapter 2
verse 23 the Quran says what in kuntum
fear Abe amendment is an other ab dinner
that to be solid to me Mythili he
weather also had a are coming do nila he
could have saw the pain which means and
if you're in doubt you took it
philosophy 101 class you're an atheist
agnostic you know believing in religion
is a dogma what does the Quran say if
you are in doubt about this book which
we have sent down to our servant
referring to the Prophet Muhammad upon
whom be peace bring one chapter like it
one chapter the shortest chapter surah
al Calvo chapter al kalfa
three lines and no one has been able to
challenge this book as Professor
Arbuthnot says although several attempts
have been made to change the Quran none
have yet succeeded and even Western
linguists and academics like Professor
Bruce
from Duke University in his book the
Koran a biography he says on page number
eight anak verses as tangible signs are
expressive of an inexhaustible truth
they signify meaning layered within
meaning lights upon light miracle after
miracle professor dr. Martin Zaman from
the Netherlands he says notwithstanding
pre-islamic poetry the Quran is the most
eminent written manifestation of the
Arabic language we have professor Neil
Robinson who converted to Islam as a
resolved understanding the Quran reading
it and knowing is a literary and
linguistic miracle that cannot be
challenged in his book the discovering
the Quran a contemporary approach Tavo
text in the chapter called the dynamic
star of the Quran he says the Quran is
amazing as a dynamic star that no on no
one can reproduce and no other classical
Arabic text can achieve what the Quran
achieves linguistically can we make it
even more simple for the people now
because they'll say that look all
religions you know all people they claim
you know if you don't believe in this
you're going to hell but really when you
investigate it there's only two its
Christianity in Islam correct me if I'm
wrong and when you invent and
investigate the claim that let's say our
brothers in humanity make the Christians
they'll say if you don't believe in
Jesus your Lord said we're going to hell
when you investigate it jesus never said
that yes he never said this and when you
investigate it further you see that he
never claimed he was God he never said
he's common died for the sins of the
world so but when you look in the Quran
doesn't the crater say that look if
anyone chooses other than submission to
the will of God is a way of life will
never be accepted and this is clear you
can go verify yes you can is that true
guys in the Quran and what's interesting
about the Christian claim of beloved
human beings brothers in humanity is
that they say the Bible is the Word of
God as we know it today and they say
that Jesus made these claims but both of
these things you can't verify we have
7,000 New Testaments in historical
record and none of them agree with one
another and it's in Greek I know big
I've read some of them myself they don't
none of them not one of them agree so we
don't know what Bible we're talking
about don't have no originals no we
don't have no original we don't have a
copy of a copy of a car
if you've evil scholars tell us desert
dr. Bruce Metzger
for example when he was talking about
the textual integrity of the Bible says
we don't know what's going on here dude
as simple as that the quran i remember i
mentioned earlier angelica neveress a
scholar
she's from she wrote the book or she
edited the book the cambridge companion
to the koran is what we have today is we
have 1400 years ago from the mouth of
the Prophet Muhammad upon whom be peace
we have all the scholarship agreeing on
this issue so one we know it's preserved
it's an English to Kenda tree miracle
and therefore we know it's from God
because it can't come from an Arab they
fell to challenge it can't come from a
non I hope can't come from Muhammad upon
whom be peace because he didn't have any
linguistic skills like the Arabs at at
that time therefore it must be from God
so the point is if God says you don't
accept this way of life you're going to
hell you should wake us up should we
should least look into yeah of course
take up the challenge that actually
because what we got at the end death and
that's too late
exactly what if we submit to what God
wants to do we got paradise and we avoid
the hell for amazing era i era yes tell
us real quick and brief help people get
a hold of you the islamic education
research academy we've launched in
england in the canada we're going to go
global soon insha'Allah and basically we
went as cool people to the way of Allah
Azza WA JAL to the way of the Prophet
Muhammad upon him be peace then we're
dedicating giving non-muslims the call
to Islam and we train Muslims on how to
give dower we go literature and leaflets
and products I aerodrome but UK check us
out real quick we got 30 seconds and the
person is doing like you he agrees that
none should be worship with the scepter
crater and not his creation and he
agrees that Muhammad is the last and
final messenger he looked him to the six
articles of faith the five pillars of
Islam really clear-cut simple and he's
lost like that nobody's giving him the
invitation tell him right now he wants
to accept Islam but you got to do well
all you have to do is just say the
following words and believe it in your
heart with conviction and certainty ash
hadu an la ilaha illallah WA ash hadu
Ana Muhammadan Rasul Allah I bear
witness there is there is no deity
worthy of worship but Allah but God and
I bear witness that Muhammad upon whom
be peace is his final messenger this is
Islam pure simple you don't need the
Muslim now your mother a Greek he wants
to know in Greektown
the Greek how do you translate this in
Greek in Greek go ahead mr. Beneke fill
a la donna la guerre or prophetess
Muhammad sallallahu wasallam inna or
prophetess to Allah so there is no God
other than Allah God and the Prophet
Muhammad upon whom be peace is His
Prophet
that's it thank you very nice very may
God Almighty the creator reward you
later on good to see you bro hey be back
again and show us Allah and it's that
simple it's that easy it's not meant to
be complicated worship the Creator not
his creation and God sent the last and
final messenger Mohammed peace be upon
him the same way if you're living during
the time of Jesus we said he'd have to
follow his teachings but Muhammad is the
last and final messenger ask God to
guide you that's the first step and
he'll facilitate away he'll facilitate a
way parting all day chasing your lusts
and desires not going to bring you
happiness no it won't but submitting to
God doing God's will will bring you
happiness you'll have peace contentment
you'll have the best in this life and
the best in the hereafter yeah life is a
challenge but when you got got off your
side you can overcome those challenges
and for every hardship God will reward
you and you'll be doing something that's
pleasing to God and then you get the
reward from God and you avoid the
Hellfire and you'll attain the paradise
give us a call 1 800 662 it's lob to
learn more to get the verbatim firt of
God for free the crown we'll see you
next time
until then peace be with you